لا تزال اخبار الحرب الميدانيه والانسانيه
في السودان تتصدر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
في العديد من البلدان العربيه والعالميه
وكان اخرها التفاعل الواسع مع رساله من اخ
لاخويه الذين لم يتوقعا ان يصبحا اعداء
يوما ما ويقفان على جبهتين مختلفتين في
اتون الحرب الطاحنه التي تمر بها البلاد
الا ان حرب ابناء الوطن الواحد لا تفرق
بين اشقاء واصدقاء ثم القصه
نشر محمد جالي الاخو الاوسط لكل من مصعب
ويعقوب رساله مؤثره في فيسبوك لاخويه
اللذين يقفان مختلفين في الحرب اذ يقاتل
الاخ الاكبر في صفوف الجيش ضد اخيه الاصغر
الذي ينتمي للقوات الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
رساله محمد انتشرت كناري في الهشيمه على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ووصف كثيرون
رساله محمد بالانيمه لانها تجسد الانقسام
والتمزق الذي يعاني منه السودان تمزق ليس
فقط بين ابناء الوطن الواحد بل بين ابناء
البطن الواحد
[موسيقى]
واعتبر الكثيرون منشوره محمد مقلقا فعلا
فقد يقتل احدهما الاخر وعندها تكون
المصيبه الكبرى حيث راى مغردون ان من مئات
الحرب في السودان ان يحارب الاخ اخاه
والخاسر الوحيد من الحرب هو الشعب
السوداني
[موسيقى]
وبعد التفاعل الكبير مع منشور محمد عاد
الى منصه فيسبوك مجددا يشكر ويطمئن
متابعيه انه تمكن من التواصل مع اخويه
وهما بصحه جيده وان اخاه فرح لخبر المولود
الجديد واتفق على تسميته محمد على اسمه
[موسيقى]